[Music]
we watch descendants too many times and
we still can't get enough of it this is
why we turn to the most popular fan
fiction stories on Wattpad to know what
could happen to our favorite characters
make sure you watch this video until the
end to know how you could be featured in
one of our videos if you love
descendants - as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you ten descendants - fan
fiction stories that are better than the
original
Neverland in this story by Darth x
Lindsey you will meet Piper Pan the
daughter of Peter Pan and her brother
Pierson the young woman was getting
ready for cotillion and even had the
chance to have a beautiful green dress
designed by Evie but life hasn't always
been perfect for her as she was once
temporarily banned from Arne Don and
lived on the Isle of the Lost
where Harry Hook became her worst enemy
this is why when she learned that Maui
back to the Isle after her fight with
Ben she knew that she had to help her so
they went to the Isle with the king who
quickly had to learn how to chill like a
villain but while they were helping him
Piper decided that she wanted to pay a
visit to one of her old friends at
Ursula's fish and chips
uma was performing what's my name but at
the end of the song all the attention
was suddenly on Piper and Harry didn't
miss this opportunity what she hated the
most about him was the way he tried to
intimidate her by flirting with her but
then she realized that he could do
something even worse King Ben had been
kidnapped and her enemy was responsible
for this she couldn't just run away
anymore Piper had to face him and if you
want to know what happens next you'll
have to read neverland by Darth X
Lindsey lost on the Isle
Harry Hook and the Isle of the Lost are
so popular that they are back in another
fan fiction story by Carmen Flair this
time mouth and Evie Jay and Carlos are
getting ready for a small trip on the
Isle you decided to join and Evie even
designed a villain outfit just for you
so you jump on the limousine and go to
the Isle of the Lost with your new
friends however as soon as you arrive
there you are quickly fascinated by
something and realize that you lost your
group you start walking around until you
end up right in front of Ursula fish and
chips this is where you meet Harry hook
who tries to intimidate you just like he
always does but as he is the only one
who ever talked to you on the eye
you asked for his help surprisingly
Perry hook does try to help you and says
that he will show you where Mouse
hideout is but after a long walk he
actually leads you to the limousine
where Mao and her friends are leaving
you try to scream but they can't hear
you you're going to have to spend the
night with Perry on the Isle he was
actually kind of nice but scary at the
same time what is going to happen next
make sure you read lost on the Isle by
carbon player on Wattpad MJ frost this
story was written by love the breeze and
this time it is about MJ frost the
daughter of Jack Frost and Morita even
though she could be a princess her
kingdom was invaded and she had to hide
on the Isle of the lost and was raised
by dr. Vasily a this is where she became
friends with now Vijay and Carlos our
villain promised that she would be back
to find her because she would always
need her evil sidekick Mao was supposed
to steal the fairy godmothers one but
she never came back
Booma was actually the one who had to
tell her the bad news and this is why
frosty decided to join her crew along
with Harry and Gil they got a lot closer
whenever they talked trash about Mao and
she was on TV she even described Harry
as a flirt and developed feelings for
him Mallett moved on and MJ tried to do
the same thing even though she couldn't
forgive her old friend who abandoned her
on the Isle she certainly wasn't ready
when she found out that her ex best
friend was back on the Isle after
leaving her boyfriend Ben the two girls
had drastically changed and things would
never be the same now that MJ is part of
limas crew and in love with Harry if you
want to know what happens next make sure
you watch MJ frost bye love the breeze
will history repeat this time Disney
dork
0:01 4 gives us the chance to see that
Peter Pan had many daughters including
Petra Pam the young girl lived and
ironed on all her life and had been told
that it was a better place than the Isle
of the Lost but she was always
fascinated by this place she sat high
above in trees to look at the Isle and
wondered what it would be like if she
lived there she didn't feel like she
belongs in auradon
at the same time Harry was looking at
Aragon and this perfect day of sunshine
thinking that it would be terrible to
live there when she went back to school
Petra accidentally made a wish when a
he was there and ended up on the Isle of
the lost the first person she met was
hairy hook and she tried to avoid him
knowing that they were supposed to hate
each other
it quickly failed as she ended up being
part of him as crew and she is witty and
quick just like her father she even got
a makeover to look just like a villain
but no one really knew who she was until
Harry hook realized that she might be
the daughter of his worst enemy you want
to know what will happen when he finds
out we'll let Disney dork 0:01
poor tell you the rest of this story oh
darling if you love Harry hook he will
be happy to hear that he is part of many
stories including this one by poi a and
once again it involves Wendy Darling and
Peter Pan's daughter Peyton pan she
loved stealing pixie dust to fly away
and escape Neverland but her father kept
saying that he wanted to keep her safe
Peter Pan was not the happy-go-lucky kid
who didn't care about the rules anymore
he had grown up to be the fairy King and
laws became stricter around there but
then Peyton found out that she would
have the chance to go to iron Don with a
full scholarship her father wouldn't let
her do that but he did enough to know
she was ready for a new adventure but
she didn't know that she would be
meeting Harry on her way to our Don
however she didn't want him to know who
she was so she said that her name was
Peyton darling just like her mother
however she finally met uma and shrimpie
quickly found out who she was and Harry
wanted her dead after what her father
did to his father she stood at the edge
of the plank and begged Harry to let her
go how is she going to find a way to
survive will at play tell you more about
this if you read their story oh darling
hooked by fire we can never get enough
of Harry Hook
and this time he inspired WWE lover 555
who also created a new character Heidi
the daughter of Hades she was part of
Houmas crew along with Harry and Gil
unfortunately her father Hades didn't
believe in her he said that her brother
was better at being bad and she should
do the same thing instead of just
hanging out with her pirate friends and
she wasn't even the leader of the group
what a shame
Heidi was affected by what he said and
Panik tried to comfort her being a
villain is harder than what you might
think but Heidi decided that she was
going to make her father proud and
become the most feared villain on the
Isle she was not going to be like Mao
the traitor who loved ever look behind
on the Isle Heidi started with her old
friend Claudine Frollo the young woman
didn't want any pirates in her shop and
Hades daughter wasn't shy to intimidate
by saying the meanest things to her
however it wasn't always easy for her to
be bad as she confessed to her friend
Harriet hook that her father used a
Punisher when she was good the young
lady was really confused
will she finally find out who she really
is and what does Harry have to do with
her and we have a clue she had a crush
on him make sure you read WWE lever five
five five story hooked by fire to find
out hooked this story was written by
little fan Victor and once again it
involves the hem from Harry hook it
started just after the fight with the
Pirates as our favorite villains had
left the aisle in the limousine and this
time we get the chance to see how
Ursula's daughter tricked Ben Harry had
never seen him is so angry before and we
totally understand why if Harry had
never called her to come and help him
Uma could have defeated now however
everything changed when Harry said that
he might have found a way to go to
auradon this was when he handed her
maleficent spellbook
uma had never been happier and this kind
of feeling is really rare on the Isle
then he gave her the chance to go before
they closed the barrier she made it to
Oregon and quickly headed to Ben's
office all she needed was a quick spell
and he was immediately hers it was as
simple as that
then she told him what she wanted him to
do he was going to bring her to the
cotillion dance and make sure that all
the residents on the Isle of the Lost
would be set free but as we all know her
plan failed and she had to go back to
the Isle we all want to know what is
coming next so make sure you had two
Wattpad to read hooked by little fan
Victor mad in love here's a story by
Czech Sarli Madeline was the daughter of
the Mad Hatter but King beasts feared
that she was going to be crazy like her
father and sent her to the Isle of the
Lost
uma didn't like her because she hated
the way she had the Isle wrapped around
her little finger
however the nice girl was one of her
best friends and Harry was kind of a
flirt like always but Madeleine was not
interested in him however there was
something that quickly caught her
attention King been with on the Isle and
they needed to bring him to Emma when
evj and Carlos found out about this
Madeline told him that mal had to meet
you man Ursula's fish and chips to find
out what was going to happen to him and
as we all know now lost and had to give
him a the fairy godmothers wand we
already know the end of the movie so
let's focus on another
the story with his new character Harry
kept flirting with Madeleine and she
realized that she was more and more
interested in him are we going to hear
about another love story on the Isle of
the Lost it just looks like everyone is
falling for Harry if you want to know if
he wins Madeline's heart - make sure you
read mad in love by Czechs early on
Wattpad mouths little sister
this time anonymous fangirls gives us
the chance to meet Melanie maleficents
youngest daughter who also happens to be
mouths little sister she met Harry hook
who was actually really nice and he
invited her to join their crew but
Melanie was born to one of the most
villainous families on the Isle and
thought that it would take her more than
a pretty face to get her to join this
kids gang Harry quickly convinced her as
she saw it was an opportunity to become
North American her sister Emma wasn't
really happy to see her but when Melanie
talked about how much she hated her
family Ursula's daughter saw her as an
asset Melanie wanted only one thing in
exchange wiping the smirks off her
sisters group however one day mount
asked her little sister if she could
hang out with her or actually forced her
chant some big news and tell her family
maleficents daughter was cordially
invited to attend auradon prep as of
King Ben's Proclamation this evil
character actually had two daughters but
they all knew who the King was talking
about her big sister ended up being the
one who into auradon but it also meant
that melanie was the only one left on
the Isle of the Lost
what is she going to do anonymous
fangirls will tell you more about this
in mouth little sister to the stars
here's our last story by Tara dark Jam
Haven was Queen of Hearts daughter who
used to be friends of the villains kids
before they left her to go to art on
she had no friend on the aisle until uma
decided to take her in they both became
very close friends and just like any
other girl she was really interested in
the area and if these poor friends had
one point in common it was that they all
hated mal now that she was living
happily ever after in auradon this is
why they were really surprised to see
the evj and Carlos were back on the Isle
along with King Ben as we have seen in
the movie they kidnapped Ben challenge
mal and asked
fairy godmothers wand in exchange
however as Haven was walking alone it
she saw Evie and mal the two girls tried
to be kind but the Queen of Hearts
daughter didn't care they were traitors
and she didn't owe them anything now
that she was helping Yuma get the wand
she was their worst enemy
so what is going to happen next you'll
have to read to the stars by Tara dark
gem and now we want to hear about your
fanfiction don't be shy to tell us about
it in the comment section down below and
it could be featured in one of our
videos that's it for 10 descendants -
fan fiction stories that are better than
the original for more stories like this
make sure you watch 10 rumors about
descendants 3 you need to hear thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]